if you want to see a sign of how bad
things are in parts of the country
the first openly gay mayor of an
Oklahoma town has resigned because of
threats to his security and harassment
now I want to mention
openly gay is not a term I usually use
because I I agree when you say openly
gay you're sort of saying like
there's shame around being gay and so we
have this category secretly gay and
openly gay like I I understand that but
the point here is we're talking about
someone who acknowledges publicly as
part of their public presence that
they're gay and this is the first such
mayor in Oklahoma and it's relevant to
the story but don't come after me about
openly gay I get it the first openly gay
mayor of a small town in Oklahoma said
he's resigning after an increase in
threats to his safety The Village mayor
Adam Graham who took on the role in May
said in the last month he's been
followed home from meetings threatened
while walking my dog harassed at
Starbucks and have had my tires slashed
he says since 2018 I fought against
ageism racism and homophobia at every
step unfortunately certain elements of
the population have recently become
emboldened to pursue threats and attacks
bordering on violence
the threats from the past month resulted
from an incident two months ago where I
stood up against Nichols Hill Police
targeting The Village residents
unfortunately these malicious bad faith
attacks are escalating and I no longer
feel safe to serve in my capacity as
mayor it is with a heavy heart I tender
my resignation sickening country and you
know what I can't blame him and yet in a
sense the terrorists win when this
happened right you terrorize the gay
mayor out of office and then you
perpetuate that probably the person who
replaces him is going to be heterosexual
and you perpetuate the homophobia they
get a win it's not a criticism of the
individual I get it I understand why
he's doing it but at the same time this
is sort of like how they win so a very
sad story and this is not I'm not even
this is not whatever country you'd
imagine this happens in
this is the United States in 2022 and
the openly gay mayor
is afraid essentially for his safety
because of the level of harassment
people following him stalking Etc
because he's gay
what else can you say extraordinarily
sad